ok ok je me présente je m'appelle moi
c'est lucas hochart vous voyez ce génie
qui sort de sa lampe et qui sourit à
tous les gens qui vont sur son [ __ ] de
sites web ou à le faire redescendre sur
terre un peu parce que là et tu
redescends épilatoire jouer fait
deviennent des personnages vous fait
deviner des objets des animaux ou des
concepts ont ils fait le tri direct
d'office ne met qu'un pas tant gêné que
ça tu vas deviner un personnage manga
pensa personnages réels ou fictifs je
vais tenter de le deviner
bonne chance cousin âge j'ai 93 ans
qu'est ce que ça peut te [ __ ] au
personnage était de sexe féminin
non il a un téléphone portable je sais
pas existe-t-il réellement non porte il
la moustache
non at il des cheveux non ethisphere jeu
vidéo non est-il jaune oui le personnage
écrit-il des romans gay bons personnages
et ils enseignants
je pense archos est ok ok on passe aux
choses sérieuses effectivement il était
fort ce génie ton personnage at il des
cheveux non à boîte ils n'ont peut-il
volet nom est il un pokémon bien tenté
gamin avec l'acide pokémon goretti un
animal non porter des vêtements non
est-il gentil non est-il méchant oui est
il issu l'animation japonaise mais
pourquoi tout de suite oui est-il géant
oui est-il rouge
oui at il des tentacules ah non allanon
ati linke nom est il complètement chauve
ouais le titan colossal mais on arrêter
avec tout ce que japonais va passer sur
une autre thématique où il a moins de
facilités pour jouer le personnage à
boîte ils n'ont attiré cheveux oui est
il issu de l'animation japonaise normes
at-il réellement existé wii party
couramment français non et idc des sexes
féminins non at il eu un rapport du
milieu du sport n'ont été un acteur non
tu as du mal à trouver petit confetti la
politique et bano imparti l'anglais
probablement at-il plus de 35 ans aurait
est-il asiatiques
oui et 28 minutes de jeu vidéo wii et il
le créateur du personnage de mario oui
je pense à shigeru miyamoto il est fort
las cet indien ces indiens [ __ ] je
pensais l'avoir fait en disant qu on
arrêter avec tout ce que japonais il m'a
bien le cours de fac qui en génisses
pareil ton personnage atypique des poils
et quatre pattes n'ont existé réellement
non partie les vêtements masculins oui
et il sut d'animation japonaise non tu
arrêtes maintenant fait-il des combats
oui et il masque et ça ne porte une cape
oui dit il à gotham et bana et banon
figure-t-il dans star wars non plus et
il joue un jeu vidéo wii montils à
cheval non at il une épée witt au
passage at-il de près ou de loin un
rapport avec nintendo non ton passage
at-il un rapport à tout jeu dark souls
oui ton personnage est si le héros un
spa de l'oeuvre dans laquelle on trouve
je pense à ton personnage dans dark
souls mais ok je sais ouvrez bien vos
oreilles ton personnage fait-il partie
du dessin animé pokémon attend le mec
direct ouais alors tiens rapport avec
les éclairs non ton personnage volts il
ouais étiez un pokémon feu non il est
légendaire non seulement aux produits de
l'avoir at il des ailes way at il un bec
ces photos passage volatile la nuit
ouais at-il la peau bleue je sais pas
fethiye vidéo à paris guy tendo cet été
en corse est aujourd'hui way est il de
petite taille
oui je pense à nostang faire non et bah
nabucco tu sais pourquoi petit [ __ ]
alors ouais je pense à nostang fairway
mais à nostang faire shiny au akinator
tu l'as vu mon et voilà les gens c'est
comme ça qu'on détruit un mythe un génie
un indien se cachant dans une lampe
n'hésitez pas et venez de ça vous a plu
et si on l'a bien indiqué je suis fier
de moi bah ouais baye laye c'est pas ma
faute s'il a pas pensé à à penser aux
pokémon shining autrement appelée
pokémon chromatique et ouais mon pote
[ __ ] j'suis roger pas sur la peur se
retrouver dans une prochaine vidéo ça
m'a bien fait marrer de docu la sec ce
[ __ ] akinator aller portez vous bien
john numbi
[Musique]